uh I just watched uh the running man
this week and at the beginning of it
there is this preamble where they talk
about what America is going to be like
in 2017 and it's about a militarized
state and uh an economic collapse and
depleted natural resource and I'm
watching this thinking there they're
just three years off because it's it's
basically happening now did you realize
that that movie although we have it we
don't have reality jail just yet but I
think we probably will reality TV jail
do you realize that movie was going to
be so ahead of its time no really I
didn't you know it was a fun movie to do
with richard dawson and arnold and all
that because the premise of the show did
you know who actually wrote the running
man are you aware of that you know what
i did my research before and i don't
remember of had tell me please
well here's well here's the deal the
running man was a short story written in
a book by a writer named Richard Bachman
well that was a pseudonym for Stephen
King Stephen King wrote the running man
is that right I can't believe it you
know when I was when I was doing
research before I watched it again the
other day I would have sworn it was a
philip k dick because that was all his
his future and nope yeah nope Stephen
King Stephen King wrote under the
pseudonym of Richard Bachman and he
wrote the running man and what it is
it's a game show of the future while
with reality TV like it is today and
when you look at where we're at right
now in 2017 the running man might be
real it's three years away yeah really
between ratings and our for-profit
prisons which we already have it
definitely as a possibility so I gotta
ask you when you did that movie and you
did predator both with Arnold
Schwarzenegger did you guys ever do you
have a political talk did you ever say
yeah you know what maybe maybe we'll be
governor's one day what do you think not
a bit you know when when we did predator
in fact I did predator and Arnold came
up to me on the set and said Jesse my
next film the running man there's a part
you're perfect for I hope you will do it
well it always get when you deal with
Hollywood when the star of the film
wants you in his film
it gives you great leverage on
negotiating yeah that's a little
Halloween to learn what when the star
wants you in the film that
you've got some leverage when it comes
time to negotiate and believe me I
exploited that leverage well speaking of
leverage did you get to keep the gun
literally the coolest gun probably in
the history of filmmaking did they let
you keep it no not at all that's the
helicopter minigun I was the first
person in predator to shoot it handheld
it shoots seven thousand rounds a minute
I think something like that
it's a it's a Gatling gun is what it is
and it I was shooting a full ammo load
didn't kick that much it's just torque
to the left a little because the barrel
swing counterclockwise but the unique
thing about the gun is its
electronically fired there's no trigger
they would run battery cables up my
pants leg and out and splice it into the
weapon and then they're gonna be guy in
the bushes and was time for me to shoot
he touched the two heads to the car
batteries and I'd start firing wow that
is unbelievable what was your classic
line there do you remember it I ain't
got time to believe